jeanette mccurdy was a popular face on
nickelodeon in the 2000s but for a
number of reasons
she's stepped back from the spotlight in
recent years here's why she's not
getting cast much anymore and what the
future has in store for her
in march 2014 three racy photos of
mccurdy were leaked online
which put the future of her nickelodeon
show sam and cat in jeopardy mccurdy
seemed to imply that the culprit behind
the leak was
nba player andre drummond whom she dated
in 2013
as she tweeted to anyone disappointed i
sent those pics to one person
you can connect the dots shocked someone
would stoop so low
i just speak with candor when people
started pointing fingers at drummond he
tweeted in response
for all the speculations about leaking
anything i have nothing to do with it
i'm focused on basketball thank you
ultimately the leaker's identity was
never definitively revealed mccurdy
later took to reddit to address the
leaked photos as well as some recent
instagram selfies as she wrote
i post to social media when i want to
and how i want to and i would whether i
was in the entertainment industry or not
i don't believe people should attack me
because their image of me is destroyed
after i post a harmless
sultry photo she added i don't believe
an actor actress should lose the rights
to be themselves in an attempt to cater
to the image that was created by a
character they played that's all
ultimately sam and cat was cancelled
after just one season
not because of mccurdy's leaked photos
but because of her rocky relationship
with nickelodeon when rumors circulated
that her co-star ariana grande was being
paid more than mccurdy grande cleared
the air on twitlonger by saying
jeanette and i agreed up front that we
would be treated equally on this show in
all regards as we should be considering
we each work just as hard as the other
on this show
fans then speculated that mccurdy and
grande didn't get along but as mccurdy
explained to e news
i just feel that ariana and i were and
are extremely close and extremely
like-minded in a lot of different ways
and then sorta as the show dissolved
everybody wanted to find some sort of
hidden meaning in our relationship
she added i think we butted heads at
times but in a very sisterly way
like she knows me so well and i know her
so well that i think it was unfortunate
that things got misconstrued
after sam and cat mccurdy moved on to a
four-part web series called what's next
for sarah which she wrote co-edited
executive produced and starred in it
premiered on vimeo on august 13
2014. taking inspiration from mccurdy's
own life she played sarah an actress
whose world begins to fall apart after a
hit show she stars on gets cancelled
many viewers speculated that a
self-absorbed character named gloriana
was based on ariana grande
partly because of a physical resemblance
mccurdy never admitted that the
character was a direct reference to her
old co-star but she did address the
subject during an interview with abc
news
so i'll ask about gloriana then oh yeah
that was definitely a character
that was heightened for comedic purposes
mccurdy further explained that there
were blogs that blew the whole thing out
of proportion and that she was just
trying to make a joke out of her own
experience
she also talked about her relationship
with grande as she revealed
we've had coffee since this web series
and everything we've talked she's
awesome and i wish her all the best and
i know that she does the same for me
another major factor in mccurdy's break
from acting was the loss of her mother
debbie in 2013.
in 1995 debbie was diagnosed with breast
cancer and initially beat it back with
treatment but 15 years later the cancer
had returned and spread as mccurdy wrote
in the wall street journal in 2011.
i can't imagine how difficult it must be
for my mother to tolerate all she has
gone through and continues to go through
the pain the worry and the battle she
wakes up every day hurting
and goes to sleep hurting even more my
mother the constant optimist and ever
vestent sprightly woman i know her to be
is caged along with this hideous beast
they call cancer
in 2015 mccarty told vulture that
instead of mourning
she worked as she put it six days after
my mom died i went back to work i
thought oh if i do this vine video or if
i do this episode if i hit every mark
then i'll be fine because i'll have
something else to focus on but really i
was just putting this huge
life-changing event on the back burner
and it was slowly causing me to unravel
to the point where i would say i got to
my lowest emotional point
throughout her career mccurdy has
suffered from eating disorders which she
opened up about in a 2019 essay in the
huffington post as she explained
my disordered eating started when i was
11. as a child actress working in
hollywood i quickly learned that
remaining physically small for my age
meant i had a better chance of booking
more roles
unfortunately i had a trusty and
dedicated companion ready to help me
with my burgeoning anorexia
my mom she added i don't hold this
against my mom at all
i don't think she could help it mom had
been hospitalized for anorexia on
several occasions when she was a
teenager and i'm not convinced she ever
overcame her disordered eating
mccurdy's anorexia would turn into binge
eating and eventually bulimia
after experiencing several come to jesus
moments such as losing a tooth and
popping blood vessels in her eyes she
finally decided that she needed help and
met an eating disorder specialist she'd
already worked with a therapist a year
and a half earlier but this time she was
committed as she wrote
the important thing was getting back on
the recovery program anytime i had a
slip so that as they say in recovery the
slip doesn't become
a slide i suggest finding something
whatever your passion is whatever your
hobby is whatever
just finding something that will satisfy
you and fulfill you after the death of
her mother mccurdy felt lost and turned
to alcohol as she explained on her
podcast empty inside in 2020
i'd be drunk in the middle of the street
in france i was supposed to do a press
junket the next day i got completely
wasted
in another episode of md inside mccurdy
discussed her struggle with
obsessive-compulsive disorder and how it
was related to her mormon upbringing
as she explained in the mormon church
they teach you about this thing called
the still small voice
you're supposed to listen for it and it
kind of guides you to do what's right
for me i confused my anxiety with the
still small voice
she added i had ocd as a kid and i'd be
like okay so my still small voice is
telling me that i need to touch this
thing
ten times before i touch this other
thing ten times so that i can then go to
the door and open this five times
because the still small voice is telling
that i need to do these things
or else my mom's going to die in her
huffington post essay about her eating
disorders mccurdy explained that she
didn't want to be a role model during
her nickelodeon days on icarly
as she put it i had become acutely aware
that i was a role model for kids which i
felt like i was supposed to find cool
but actually found upsetting my great
contribution to society was walking onto
an overlit nickelodeon set shouting
lines about fried chicken
and that's what kids were looking up to
can i have a chicken pox
you want one of my chicken packs just
one puck
yeah no mccurdy further explained
there was something about the
shallowness of my success that made me
resent it that resentment
festered providing even more fuel for my
disordered eating i actively began to
engage in anorexic behavior again
obviously not everyone has to be perfect
but mccurdy found it especially absurd
to be seen as a role model for playing
an obnoxious character on a children's
show
not to mention that this was all going
on while her mother was dying and she
was suffering from disordered eating
in december 2020 it was reported that an
icarly revival with most of the original
cast was set to stream on paramount plus
but one cast member not returning was
jeanette mccurdy eight months earlier
mccurdy told elite daily that she
doesn't look back fondly on the show
as she put it i still have complicated
feelings toward my past from my
experience with nickelodeon
it's something that i work on i'd like
to get to a place of peace with my past
that would be great
on the bright side though mccurdy was at
least happy for the time she spent with
her icarly co-workers as she noted
i would not have such an enjoyable life
if these people weren't in it
the human connections you have with
people is always what determines whether
ultimately something is a good or bad
experience
while mccurdy has mixed feelings about
her icarly days it's at least heartening
to hear about the special connections
she made during her time on the show
beginning in 2015 mccurdy starred on the
canadian sci-fi series between
it ran for two seasons and after it
wasn't renewed for a third she decided
to take a break from acting and focus on
other projects this was ultimately part
of an effort to work on something she
could truly be happy about as she told
the hollywood reporter in 2018
i never got the chance to be cast in a
project i was proud to be part of
now i have a better chance of making
things i'm proud of than getting cast in
things i'm proud of
mccurdy assembled an all-female crew as
she wrote and directed the short film
kenny which was inspired by her mother's
death
it premiered in 2018 on short of the
week a youtube channel that showcases
short films from around the world
mccurdy has also written and directed
other short films like the mccurdy's
which is based on her childhood
and strong independent women which
covers eating disorders
in 2020 mccurdy started hosting the
podcast empty inside which covers many
personal topics
such as stage parents rejection and
dating her guests have included the
likes of former american idol contestant
david archuleta filmmaker zane rubin and
comedian taylor tomlinson
mccurdy may not be acting much these
days but she appears to be doing what
makes her happy
in a february 2021 episode of empty
inside mccurdy officially announced that
she wouldn't return to acting anytime
soon as she put it i quit a few years
ago because i initially didn't want to
do it my mom put me in it when i was six
and by age 10 or 11 i was the main
financial support for my family
and it was very much just like the
pressure of my family didn't have a lot
of money and this was kind of the way
out which i actually think was helpful
in driving me to some degree of success
mccurdy also noted that acting was
difficult because of her nerves during
auditions and that she lost much of her
interest in acting after her mom died
with her death kind of died a lot of her
ideas for my life and that was
that was its own its own journey and a
difficult one for sure she also
reiterated that she feels ashamed of
many roles that she played
as she explained i resent my career in a
lot of ways i feel so unfulfilled by the
roles that i played and felt like it was
the most cheesy
embarrassing i did the shows that i was
on from like 13 to 21 and by 15 i was
already embarrassed
my friends at 15 they're not like oh
cool you're on this nickelodeon show
it was embarrassing we're sad to hear
that mccurdy has no intentions of acting
again anytime soon but we're glad that
she's now choosing to do what makes her
happy
if you or someone you know is struggling
with addiction please call the substance
abuse and mental health administration's
24 7 national helpline
at 1-800-662-help that's 1-800-662-4357